6 12. on a monday morning we love to
take trips into las vegas unique past
and this morning we're taking a look at
our own past the legacy of channel 8 and
former station owner eccentric
billionaire howard hughes so there's a
building in our parking lot and we
called the hughes house he stayed there
in the 1950s
he lived here in the 50s before becoming
the recluse that you've seen pictures of
sheltered at the top of the desert inn
hotel
it was one of only three homes that he
lived in during his life george knapp
enlists the help of legendary newsman
bob stoddall who now sits on the local
historic preservation board
this is a transition point in his life
coming and staying at the at the
greenhouse
when was he actually here i started in
the spring of 1953
and left uh um eight or nine months
months later in in 54. but he lived here
he was staying here he he was staying
here and and you could tell he was
staying here because when when it was
opened
there was a loaf of bread
half eaten
uh the the the cabinets were filled with
these little cereals uh post cereal roy
rogers little uh thing so this is where
he
he slept and he ate had breakfast in the
morning or whatever his morning you know
could be
what was going on in hughes's life and
in the world at that time
well in 1953
uh
we had just
ended so to speak with an armistice of
the korean war and that was in july of
53. that's been going on since
for the previous two or three years
we're right in the middle of the cold
war
and hughes at that moment while he was
in this house was thinking still
thinking about building a defense plant
in in southern nevada right where
summerlin is now because he owned all
that land that he bought in the in the
mid-40s
pre-about 1942 or 43-44
and he wanted to build the defense plant
there
he started
creating and and having written a film a
movie about las vegas with jane russell
and vincent price and and that premiered
in february of 1952 here here in las
vegas las vegas had been shooting for
the previous 12 8 18 months so he had
really refocused his life into into las
vegas he liked las vegas he liked
in the sense the small town of it other
than there was the entertainment and the
casinos that he could quietly go in and
wouldn't be bothered
where in los angeles he didn't he didn't
feel comfortable doing that
so i guess this was the perfect place to
be a recluse right in las vegas
the hughes house was also used for a
scene in the famous mob movie casino
it's about the las vegas mobsters lefty
rosenthal and tony spelatro they're
played by robert de niro and joe pesci
in the movie the hughes house was used
as the home of the character portrayed
by james woods it's seen when sharon
stone's character runs off to la with
him
our hughes house special aired last
night so you can find more stories about
the history of it on our website oh wow
history wow it's incredible because you
just come up on it like you said heather
when you first start to work here you go
what is that yeah
kind of mint green it looks like it's
from the 50s
and the lawn is manicured well and the
legend of howard hughes owning the
station has to do with watching movies
in the middle of the night right
absolutely so the story goes that this
long before cable and
movies on demand
so they would show movies overnight
howard hughes would fall asleep he would
call the tv station to go i fell asleep
turn it back
and people who are at home watching
would go wait a minute didn't we just
see that oh it must be mr hughes again
he wanted to say he wanted to watch some
people people got to know that that was
mr hughes probably oh my gosh so we were
the beginning of dvr and rewind
high demand
but then the next step in that story is
they said look if you're going to call
and demand that we replay the movie or
or change it up why don't you just buy
the tv station and do it yourself and
that's exactly what he did he bought a
channel
and so he could demand whatever actions
he wanted it's an expensive remote
control
on on-demand video right here